some of y'all are getting confused on what the modern day tradwife is
Emphasis on the modern
but still very much high key traditional in this sense
that she likes to take care of you
her home, herself
she's very feminine
but she still values herself and she doesn’t handle disrespect
The modern day trad wife loves to cook, clean
take care of her home
take care of her husband
but she still might be a little unconventionally traditional or untraditional
she might have tattoos
maybe she's a little freaky
but she still does not handle disrespect
just because she likes to cook and clean for you and take care of you
does not mean that she doesn't value herself
she's still expresses herself freely however she would like
because the man allows her to be in her feminine energy
I don't know, if you want 100% tradwife
go back to the 50s
the year is 2024
so you have to take some of the untraditional with the traditional
in order to get the full package
Times have changed
You might still find a woman who is the hundred percent traditional route
but in today's day and age
you have to accept some of the untraditional to get the traditional
Once you realize that
that not so cookie cutter woman
becomes your most rewarding prize in life